hey guys how's it goin so I'm really
excited so it's my sister Bree Ann's
birthday actually it's both of our
sister breeds birthday and I wanted to
get her something really special and as
you guys know she has a dog named Bo
yours Bo you put your bow here is a
stuffed bow so there's a while ago
my two favorite pigs ever Percy and
Poppleton they made stuffed pig versions
of themselves and I've been obsessed
with the services called cuddle clones
where you can basically take pictures of
your pet send it to them and they give
you a life size and salt life size but
yeah it was given a little like like
he's really this is the problem with
having like all Blacky animal I know
real life doesn't but it's honestly
stripe so he looks just like he looks
just like Bo Bo's got his little stripe
here and they'll always has this little
tongue out and stuff Joanie's all upset
because i'm not gonna get to be able to
go home and Jenna's gonna be able to go
home and take Bo and put him next to the
real Bo
don't let me touch him because he will
eat him I will not this looks freaking
exactly like both they take like the
measurements
I mean you send them pictures and you
would have them pretty much do whatever
you want you could have them like
sitting and laying down they do take a
while to come in so if you guys do plan
on ordering those gifts you're gonna
need to order to advance you have to
film freeze reaction bill and I will
okay
you must well okay we can cut to freeze
reaction here's pretty fake cuddle clone
Bo has made it home safely with me to
seeing that you told me to record
Brienne's reaction so that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna go get brie cuddle
cuddle o mo and real bo is here too so
this is great okay here we go
hey Bri are you ready okay well okay Bri
are you ready for your present
yeah okay close your eyes okay put your
hands out
hold it oh this is the cutest thing ever
I'm just gonna come I don't have you
know you can't play like that huh oh boy
oh boy boy can't tell which is winner no
she can't eat it but let me see you
can't let him just hug it
just let him hug okay you have to be
nice nice huh
he's like I'm confused this is me give
us that back come here Pig it's so cool
about me and here's my other baby now oh
look do you guys look alike oh my gosh
is me freaking - he's really cute when
you feel like move his little ladies and
spa you can sit down we should get him a
nice little this came look she get ever
smaller so you get him a collar wait
check out cuddle clothes pretty much
everywhere on the internet and I'm love
with the Bobo
you